so who broke
it I'm not mad I just want to
know I did I broke no no you didn't Tom
don't look at me look at Ben what I
didn't break it huh that's weird how'
you even know it was broken because it's
sitting right in front of us and it's
broken spicious no it's not if it
matters probably not but April was the
last one to use liar I don't even drink
that crap oh really then what were you
doing by the coffee cart earlier I used
the wooden stirs to push back my
cuticles everyone knows that Jerry okay
let's not fight I broke it let me pay
for it run no who broke
it Ron Don has been awfully quiet really
yeah
really I broke it it burned my hand so I
punched
it I predict 10 minutes from now they'll
be at each other's throats with war pain
on their faces and a pig head on a stick
good I was getting a little chummy
around
here Bobby Newports never had a real job
in his life you got to give it more
attitude it's got to scare people Bobby
Newport yeah okay all
right Bobby Newports never had a real
job in his life Bobby newport's never
had a real job in his life Bobby Newport
Bobby Newport Bobby Newport Bobby
Newport Bobby Newport Newport Bobby
Bobby Bobby Newport all right now we're
just wasting time Jerry e h 4 M potato
shape coffee mug shape smudge smudge
middle finger smudge the rest are all
smudges oh my God you drove us here we
made like 100 million doctor's
appointments for ourselves in one week
after this we won't have to go to doctor
for like 10 years because we're
smart night Ron night
Ron ladies
ladies
[Applause]
you know what Go Dino Dash out of the
way yeah woo
wo I call an ambulance a different
ambulance the one I ran
[Applause]
into
it Tom I couldn't afford enough premium
carpet to get us to the stage I mean it
was a short walk but it was pretty
luxurious
right
okay
everybody smile away smile
away get up and
it on
your stop leaning on my arm
[Music]
Andy
babe I'm holding the dog he is peeing
he's now peeing and I'm putting him down
Ronnie only has three legs
[Music]
scared run there's no stares how do I
get to the
stage
your get up and make it happen
okay okay ready
and Jerry God
gross oh
Jerry
guys oh god oh I think he might be
having a heart attack what are you
serious oh so much stuff is happening
right now call 911 okay just breathe
okay you're going to be fine no jeez did
a dinosaur just fart Jerry get a grip
sorry guys Fu apology not accepted stop
talking I wish I could stop
smelling dude seriously Jerry did you
eat farts for lunch Tom Jerry's having a
heart attack oh no I didn't know that
Jerry you
okay go go go go go go go go
go yeah oh my God that so hot that was
horrible I'm going to die I'm so
tired everything hurts running is
impossible what are you doing Tom now is
not the time for criticism how did he do
Andy finishes two mile run in 29 minutes
and 43 seconds no I'm never going to be
a
cop I'm going to have to be a robber oh
come on hang in there pal I'm going to
drive around
Andy I'm proud of you not because of
what you did which was terrible but
because of what I'm going to be able to
get you to do I guess I'm proud of me
thanks man me too we have so much work
to
do
Chris I'm dying I was dying earlier
today and then I died now I'm dead I had
to cancel a date with shaa mway tweep
and I really like
do you think she to like me now that I'm
dead what is this it's food
poisoning I have it too I did not sleep
for one second last night and I cracked
the bottom of the toilet bowl oh God
don't say that has anybody talk to Tom I
can't even imagine what that tiny little
man must be feeling like I have voided
more than Tom's body weight in the last
12 hours alone he might have just
disappeared off the Earth we need to
call him we must reach out to him
I can't do
it
Ben extension
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster I had to also I had a
banana on the way over here sorry and I
get why you don't want anyone to know
about Duke silver and you don't have to
worry your secret is safe with me to
even it out I'm going to tell you all of
my secrets oh no that's not necessary I
once forgot to brush my teeth for 5
weeks I didn't actually sell my last car
I just forgot where I parked it I don't
know who Al Gore is and at this point
I'm too afraid to ask when they say 2%
milk I don't know what the other 98% is
when I was a baby my head was so big
scientist it experiments on me I once
threw a beer at a swan and then it
attacked my niece Rebecca I'm going to
go powder my nose amongst other things
if you know what I
mean is she going to powder her
vagina
Leslie I'm
here we have to go hire a new PR
director for the health department oh my
God I'm so hung over I've never been
this hung over I feel great I ran 5K
this morning really no I threw up in the
shower my parents make me so mad
sometimes just like the time they
couldn't decide who gets a dog so they
just dropped off the local synagogue I
was
like say
what hold on Ron hold that thought just
for a
sec hey honeyy hey uh it's your me it's
wife it's lesie uh nope I have very big
news for you oh well my teeth are blue
blueberries are alcohol are you a stroke
I was just sayin around it my dog's
Jewish oh phone water Ben hello oh hello
hi Leslie it's dead
hello you Leslie sounded weird I don't
want to wait for Tom I want to walk home
I'll join you I'm always game for a
brisk walk also if I leave you alone I'm
pretty sure you'll die home is that
way watch out for that
fence okay so now you're sure that
everything is okay you know down there
you're perfectly
healthy that man has the the largest
penis I have ever seen actually don't
even know if you ask mops forgot to look
I was
distracted by the largest penis I have
ever
seen